was there anything going on with you in
your personal professional life that
shaped the origins of this script yes
first of all you know without getting
into too much detail there was a there
is a character like like Zacks character
in my life and that person was basically
due to inherent a family business and
the entire concept of inheritance of
family business was fascinating to me
and also mental illness and the the
challenges of this person's commitment
to their illness and and their
resistance to therapy and change and
sort of saying like what what are the
resisting are they aware of it you know
because it's the highs are so high and
the other thing that happened is is that
at that point we were talking earlier I
went to an all-boys school and I had a
lot of camaraderie with a couple of my
friends we were not you know football
kind of friends or anything like that
but we we I they had disappeared from my
life and I can actually got married
after I got married and it took a little
while because I thought everyone was
going to get married and they did a lot
of them still weren't married even at
that point and i got married pretty
young for that time anyway that varies
from generation generation but uh and I
just sort of was like what was that was
that was that real I mean these are
people who I shared everything with and
then it became acutely aware of the way
that the media entertainment in
particular sort of fetishized this male
friendship and friendship in general and
the the the falseness that went with it
and the kind of wish fulfillment that
was being presented and I said I think
that it actually is something very
substantial and I would like to know
where we holding each other back where
we just as phase in each other's lives
and what was holding us together at all
because that person knew me a very very
clear me you know it's a first wife in
some way you know I like the idea of
playing with the persona I mean I wrote
this for for Owen of playing with the
person Wilson's persona as a sort of you
know glib snarky easygoing stoner
that's his persona and saying like well
how is that person like that and you
only see these two guys going on a trip
together and why are they friends and
what is the substance of it and are they
even aware of how important this is in
their life and the kind of anesthetize
ation let you know that that you would
see Zack and Owen start off in bromance
or whose word didn't exist at the time
but and and basically kind of
structurally have have the the the
bottom pulled out of it tonally and say
wait a minute this guy's a drug problem
and this guy's mentally ill and a lot of
us have someone like this in our life
and you do say you know as as amy
poehler's character safety are you
hiding in charity are you are you
existing this way because there's
someone who's worse off than you can you
live very very you know irresponsibly
because this is a virtue in your life
that he's taking care of that guy and
then you say well there's real lovin it
and they there someone who knows you and
what is the compromise of both of these
people becoming adults of living on
medication and sobriety and facing
whatever the responsibilities are of
actually being in the moment in dealing
with real feelings which is to me like
you know that's a that's a very upbeat
answer to a very bleak question I mean a
lot of the the thematic nature that has
to do with our inability to feel being
accentuated by being divorced from
nature that is came from my kids that
was the thing that my six-year-old you
know I would watch The Weather Channel
when I was getting dressed in the
morning and he would walk out in the
balcony and say it's going to rain I'm
like how do you know that and he goes
smell it I was like I really and a
hundred percent accuracy and you're like
well what did I lose it's like when you
realize I mean some of it probably is
biology you can't hold all that
information but you know people who live
on farms are aware of it and and the
other thing is that you know I read this
amazing book called the language older
than words I'm not a vegetarian I'm
you know but the guys thesis is
basically that our ability to allow I
mean every society has someone who kills
the animals but our ability to be so
divorced from the process of having our
food is our ability to be cruel to each
other so I was very interested in like
writing a story where that where the the
main character had a moment of clarity
when because he had to kill his own
dinner and I think you watched the movie
and it may be totally difficult for
people but I don't know you don't think
he's going to do it and I think you are
in his shoes and it's the first honest
thing that guy ever did in his life you
said that you had written this
specifically the Steve Dallas part for
Owen Wilson at what point you show him
the script at what point does that kind
of come together it was a very
interesting thing because I had told
people I was interested in him meeting
Owen was an incoming phone call from his
agent saying he was a big fan of the
show and I knew Bogdanovich who's a very
close friend of Owens I knew Peter from
from sopranos and he had always been
supported the episode that he directed
there actually and he had always been
really supportive my work and loved the
show and he said and so the agent said
Owen wants to meet you so we went to
dinner and is one of these things
because I'd really like to do something
together and I was like it's funny today
that here as i wrote yeah i wrote this
script for you eight years ago and i've
never been able to get it to you did you
actually bring it with you to know not
that it did make it a bar said I know
we're supposed to become friends and
everything but I got you know I do I did
I actually wrote something for you and
it was like okay well let me read it and
then the yes came in honestly within
like 10 days I think another actor
pointed out Zach to you is that correct
yeah Jon Hamm Jon Hamm told me about
Zach Zach was not on anybody's radar
when I wrote the script I had always
besides Owen obviously I'd always had
this fantasy casting of Chevy Chase and
John Belushi and um and so by met Zach
and you know he's just like the warmest
most interesting person and then his
career took off and we're like well do
you really want to do this can you have
time to do it and i think that the
goodwill of the show and my passion for
it
fact that I wouldn't leave them alone
you know made it happen I think that
what what audiences do take away from
this and what when I hope that take away
from it may be two different things but
I do think that when entertainment is
successful in any way you feel less
alone and that they perhaps value their
relationships and try and like take
stock of them and that they that at some
point in the next 2436 hours or even
months from now that something in this
movie hits them as as being true and
that fat that to me that's what I want
from entertainment I don't care what it
is I want to feel less alone I want to
see that someone has a piece of the
experience that I'm having and you know
that the sentence that i started the the
film with is you know is this concept of
friendship and that it shouldn't be
trivialized or thrown away or treated
like you know that's the this the it's
not the second string of relationships
it is it is a very very unusual and
special thing very well said matthew
whiner thank you so much for coming in
oh thank you everybody